I had been dumped by this girl she said
she was looking into her future she
couldn't see me in it she wanted to be
successful in life she wanted to have
stuff she thought I was going to be a
loser you're talking about you're going
to become a crazy famous stunt man with
a video camera like I don't get it her
name her name was Tracy but it hurts so
much to be told that she thought I was
just going to be a loser in life that
when I proceeded on with the video
camera and trying to do the stunts every
year Tracy received a VHS tape of how
badass the filming that I did like each
year the tape that I mailed to Tracy got
more and more bad how long were you
doing that for she dump me in 1993 I
certainly mailed a tape in 1996 1997 by
1998 there were actual like professional
Graphics baked in because I was showing
up in like I think the more gangster
version is nothing and just know you're
going to get that Outreach in 10 years